[Music]
in 2006 a trophy hunter shot what he
thought was a polar bear in the
northwest territories of the canadian
arctic
but what he killed instead was something
never before documented in the wild
a bear with the white fur of a polar
bear but the long claws
humped back shallow face and brown
patches of fur like a grizzly
this was definitely not a typical bear
officials seized the creature its
species unknown and under
question a dna test was conducted and
led them to discover it was neither a
grizzly or a polar bear
but a hybrid with a polar bear mother
and a grizzly bear father
the first ever discovered in the wild
and while this hybrid which is now
called a pisley or a growler
was a rare discovery it may be just the
beginning of an era of these hybrid
bears
since then sightings of the hybrids have
been increasing
with a 2017 study showing eight hybrids
springing from a single female polar
bear
who mated with two grizzly bears but
it's not just the bears
in 1990 a scientist noticed a very
strange skull
hanging on an inuit hunter's wall it
looked like neither a beluga whale skull
nor a narwhal skull but something in
between
later genetic analysis would show that
the skull belonged to a narwhal beluga
hybrid
the first ever confirmed case hybrids
are commonly thought of as an
interesting anomaly but besides that
evolutionarily
useless the thinking has always been
even if
a hybrid can exist that's the end of the
line since hybrids themselves are
thought to be incapable of producing
offspring
but now scientists are understanding
that there's more to the story
and in the current state of the world
experts think we might be entering a new
era of hybrid animals but what benefit
can mating across
species lines possibly give what is
pushing animals to hybridize
and how is it even possible for animals
of different species to mate
everyone has heard of mules a mashup of
a horse and a donkey
and maybe even ligers a mix of a tiger
and a lion
hybrids are made when two different
species interbreed and produce
offspring in vertebrates it's always
been thought to be a rare occurrence
logically it seems like different
species should not be able to mate
because of the very definition of the
word species
a widely accepted concept in biology is
called the biological species concept
it says that organisms belong to the
same species
if they can interbreed and produce
viable and fertile offspring
speciation is a gradual process that
depends on
random mutations to introduce new traits
that create a sub-population
better suited for an environment or
finding a mate
eventually they become isolated both
physically and genetically
due to a diverging genome resulting in
new species
that are unable to mate with their
ancestors or each other
due to a number of barriers called
mechanisms of reproductive isolation
these work in two ways the first is by
making it
impossible for two different species to
physically mate
these are prezygotic barriers meaning
they take place before the formation of
a zygote which is the result of a sperm
and egg fusing
these include mechanisms like living in
different habitats
or having different courtship behaviors
or not having reproductive organs that
fit together
the other way reproductive isolation
works is by making it impossible for
embryos to develop into healthy
fertile adults these are called
post-zygotic barriers and are typically
the result of a mismatch of chromosomes
normally when two animals mate they each
contribute the same number of
chromosomes to their offspring
human cells contain 46 chromosomes for
example
with 23 coming from our mothers and 23
from our fathers
but now let's look at horses and donkeys
which diverged from their common
ancestor around 4 million years ago
donkeys and horses have a major problem
if they want to mate
horses have 64 chromosomes while donkeys
only have 62.
when they mate the mule offspring gets
32
chromosomes from its horse mother and 31
chromosomes from its donkey dad
this is close enough to create a living
animal but not close enough for it to
ever have its own offspring
for a male and female mule to produce
their own offspring they would have to
produce
gametes to form gametes the chromosomes
need to pair
up which requires genetic similarity
between the chromosomes
and the same number of them donkey and
horse dna is similar enough
for some pairing of the chromosomes as
is the case with pairs 1-13
and horse chromosomes 14-19 and donkey
25-30
but the rest have no direct homologs in
the other species
making the cell division that creates
haploid gametes impossible
because of reasons like this for a long
time researchers considered the
hybridization of animals in the wild of
fluke
having little significance in the big
picture of evolution
but it turns out as environments change
the barriers separating
species from one another can become less
rigid or disappear altogether
opening the door for animals to mate
across species lines
[Music]
genetically post-zygotic barriers can be
broken if
two species diverged recently enough in
the tree of life
horses and donkeys diverged around 4
million years ago
and in that time their genetics drifted
to a point where they could mate
but their chromosomes no longer aligned
for most animal combinations
even getting that far is impossible but
grizzly bears and polar bears
only diverged around 150 000 years ago
this means their genetics have not had a
chance to drift as far
they each still have 74 chromosomes
and enough genetic similarity that the
two species can
mate and produce viable fertile
offspring
as for the narluga we don't know if it
would be able to produce viable
offspring
but both narwhals and belugas have 44
chromosomes
so it may indeed be possible these
post-zygotic barriers
change on a time scale of hundreds of
thousands or millions of years
pre-zygotic barriers on the other hand
can change in a relative blink of an eye
the pre-zygotic barriers separating
polar bears and brown bears are
behavioral isolation and habitat
isolation
grizzlies live on land and polar bears
live on sea ice
some ice remains year round in the
arctic providing
vital habitat for wildlife such as seals
and polar bears
but sea ice that persists in the arctic
for more than a year
has been disappearing rapidly since the
70s
when satellite records began we know
that it's been declining at a rate of
around 13 percent per
decade and this is bad news for the
polar bears
because the sea ice is a polar bear's
hunting ground when polar bears diverged
from brown bears 150
000 years ago the last ice age was
coming to a close
the speciation occurred when a
population of brown bears followed
retreating ice northward
and adapted specifically to their new
arctic home
their home is disappearing and they are
not well suited to anything else
but with no choice they are forced south
onto land
where they can forage seabird eggs and
caribou albeit not always with much
success
and as the polar bears are forced south
grizzlies move
north pushed by increasing human
construction
and development these two types of bear
are increasingly crossing paths
and the prezygotic barriers are
beginning to dissolve
for other animals like narwhals and
belugas changing sea ice patterns may be
affecting their mating behaviors too
however both species of whale breed at a
time of year when thick sea ice prevents
research boats from getting in
so we don't actually know very much
about what exact pressures may be
spurring the existence of narlugas
we can see how circumstances may push
certain animals together
but besides just an increase in chance
encounters
there may be a deeper reason hybrids are
popping up in the world more and more
with new species come new survival
tactics
some such as narlugas carve out their
own ecological niche
one that is different from both of their
parents belugas have 40 teeth for
example
and narwhals have none narlugas split
the difference with 18.
and like a beluga narlugas have small
teeth
but like a narwhals tusk these teeth are
twisted
and this is thought to be the reason why
narluga don't feed on the same stuff as
their parents
like fish octopuses and shrimp found in
the middle of the water column
but instead feed off the bottom of the
ocean
like walruses do as environments change
this new ability could unlock an
underutilized food resource
in that area pizzlies too have
advantages that their parents do not
polar bears are struggling to survive
without their usual hunting grounds
and their population is expected to
decline by over 30 percent in the next
30 years
their skulls and teeth are built for a
very specific food source that's hard to
find in their new home
blubber pizzlies on the other hand may
have inherited some useful traits from
grizzly bears which are able to eat
pretty much anything
grizzlies are formidable scavengers with
diets that consist of insects a variety
of plants
roots tubers grasses berries rodents
fish
carry on along with other meat sources
generalist animals like grizzlies are
the best survivors of rapid change to
their environment
not highly specialized apex predators
like polar bears
so inheriting these generalist traits
could make pisleys the new
king in the north and this may mean that
a polar bear lineage may only be able to
live on within the hybridized pisleys
even as pure polar bears are pushed
closer to extinction
and in yet another sad blow to polar
bears
their hybrid versions may accelerate the
decline of their purebred relatives
out competing them even further and with
hybrid offspring replacing purebred
offspring
losing polar bears is undoubtedly a
terrible tragedy
but pisleys may be a necessary
compromise given the current warming
trends
but as depressing as the plight of the
polar bear is
hybridization is not always a sad last
resort
it can also increase biodiversity by
creating more species
like in the case of the african cichlids
these little fish
hybridize like crazy and when two
different species get together their
gene pool gets much larger
allowing for genetic variation among
offspring and soon leading to many new
species
the classic method of speciation where a
genetic mutation
gradually leads to one or two new
species over many generations takes a
long
long time but hybridization can create
new species
much faster in just the 15 000 years
since lake victoria formed
around 500 new species of cichlids have
been
created and hybridization is a part of
our past
too around 60 000 years ago our
ancestors mated with
two other now extinct species of humans
neanderthals and denisovans as their
offspring continued to mate with our
ancestors
their genes have been passed down
through each generation to us
now in some populations as much as two
percent of dna
comes from neanderthals and up to six
percent from denisovans
this translates to hundreds of genes as
scientists continue their investigation
into hybrids through fossil records and
genetics
the tree of life that we often associate
with the evolution of species
is looking less and less accurate
instead we could picture a web of life
with interbreeding and hybridization
occurring throughout the evolutionary
process
bringing about new and at times improved
species
there's always so much happening in the
world with climate change
economics and technology but in the last
few years
i stopped watching or reading the news
it was stressing me out too much to wake
up and have people arguing and yelling
at me immediately
so to stay in touch with the world i was
waking up and browsing the usual social
media platforms to see the latest news
but this too comes with a dose of
terribleness and it's not the best way
to start the day
but i still wanted to be able to join in
on conversations about what
bitcoin is up to or how jeff bezos and
company are floating around in space
and the answer i found to start my day
and to keep me up to date is morning
brew
morning brew is a completely free
curated newsletter that is delivered
straight to your inbox monday through
sunday
it gets you up to speed on business
finance and tech in just five
minutes without being dry and boring
it's a quick read and one that is witty
relevant and informative just the other
day i got the details about the
space flight measuring contest between
jeff bezos and richard branson
and learned about the shortest ever
recession in u.s history that happened
last year
it's a more healthy reasonable and
tempered way to wake up
and there's really no reason not to sign
up there's no commitment
and it's completely free it takes less
than 15 seconds to sign up
and doing so helps this channel so click
the link in the description to get
started with morning brew today
and if you're looking for something else
to watch right now you can watch real
engineering's latest video about the
uncertain future of jet fuel
and the end of cheap travel or watch
this channel's most recent video
explaining the science behind the
mystery of allergies